[Music]
6 41 here on a wednesday morning it is
time once again for our morning cup of
joe's segment we are joined live by
metro sheriff joe lombardo
sheriff good to see you once again
thanks for joining us this morning
appreciate it
good morning john it's good to see you
in the studio i know somehow they let me
back in for a change
let's talk about the the news of the day
the news of the last couple of weeks
we saw the ride on capitol hill in
washington d.c last week
the las vegas sun reported yesterday
that metro police was
investigating whether officers from here
in in las vegas
were over in washington during that
event can you talk about the
investigation
and what's being done at a department
level to look into this
yeah i think it's a similar uh proactive
step that
all the police departments across the
nation are taking uh
because i think it's important for us in
law enforcement to have that sense of
objectivity and you know people have
their first amendment right to do what
they want to do but in that case
uh it went beyond that and so i think
it'd be troublesome for
an individual to be part of the law
enforcement community
knowing that they entered the capital
and did
insurrection is the word being used
today
and it's important for us to
identify an individual if they did that
and do whatever we can to remove them
from
the law enforcement community
it it i support what they
what people want to do but obviously in
this case it just went beyond
desire to protest versus becoming a riot
are you aware of any officers that did
uh go into the capitol
no as of today no um but we're working
hand in hand with the fbi
and we're going through all the videos
and relying on people to call in if they
know
um and we'll do an intensive follow-up
if
in fact we do identify somebody kind of
jumping off of that we heard from
federal authorities that they're
prepared for possible
large demonstrations on inauguration day
in state capitals obviously that's up in
carson city but
uh what is metro doing uh just to
prepare uh here in southern nevada for
what might happen next week
yeah you know and it's unfortunate that
we're already prepared for
these type of incidents um you know
during the summer time with the
uh protests associated with george floyd
and everything else and
we've been dealing with in society in
the last few months
to include covet and what i mean by that
unfortunately we've had plenty of
practice
with the people out protesting doing
their first amendment rights and
everything else that goes along with it
but in this case
there was a warning obviously the
president said what he said
and individuals weren't prepared and
that's my opinion i believe law
enforcement was
ill-prepared to deal with the situation
that took place and so now we have a
warning
we we're aware that there may be
interesting
occurring here on the 20th and we're
putting people in place and plans in
place to
to address it accordingly and so after
that event
in dc in proximity and during that event
in dc we did deploy troops here to the
local courthouse federal courthouse and
the state capitol
so we've had sufficient warning
associated with it and
it's a failure of leadership if we do
not respond to that warning
and i believe that's what happened in
washington d.c
um sheriff let's switch gears quickly to
coronavirus vaccines you and i have
talked before about the effect of covet
on the department uh from top to bottom
will you require officers to get a
vaccination and get immunized
uh well first and foremost uh thank you
for asking the question
because there is always a concern with
your first responders
becoming victims of the virus so to just
put it in perspective i've had
over a thousand employees to date uh
since march of last year um that have
come back positive for
cobit so we're dealing with that as a
workforce and a labor
issue and all the contact tracing that
goes along with it and
people gone on a daily basis and doing
what we're
paid to do and fighting crime so moving
forward the vaccines available
they made it in us in the first tier
as far as going to get the initial shot
and then subsequently the second shot
so it is it's voluntary um i guess
that's the core of your question
it's voluntary at this point because of
collective bargaining and everything
else that you could imagine
but up until the vaccine
was available it was presumptive that
you if you were positive you received it
at work and we took care of your time
off
and now as we move forward with the
vaccine being available it's no longer
presumptive
and so we're encouraging our employees
to go get the vaccine
so we can ensure that we continue to be
a viable
and robust workforce so it's a
three-phase attempt for us
for the first responders office
commission officers and the
corrections officers in the jail are
first to go and then it's the follow-up
of the rest of the police officers in
the second phase and the third phase
will be our civilian employees
and we have a suspense date of april
first for the second shot to be
completed
okay so it's it's encouraged but not
required just because of collective
bargaining
i think we have time to quickly sneak in
a quick question about dui crashes in
the valley we've seen
some relatively high profile ones can
you just talk quickly about the effort
to fight the issue here as we start the
new year have things been improving
recently since the holidays
well since the holidays no
it's actually been had we've had a
significant increase in fatal accidents
associated with uh
dui in the first month of the year of
the calendar year
but if you look at compared to 19 versus
20
of last year we had a 11 decrease in
fatal accidents associated with dui
so that's positive but we're
experiencing a significant increase here
in the first month
more people are driving people are
getting back to work
no matter how many times we preach it
you know dui is bad and you have all the
options
of uber and lyft and everything else um
it seems to still be happening which is
troublesome to me
personally and for the community um so
we have to continue to fight the fight
and educate people
and do uh enforcement whenever possible
to try to curb the
this particular issue all right well
sheriff we will certainly keep an eye on
that we appreciate you joining us this
morning and answering our questions take
care and we'll catch up with you later
if you have a question for sheriff
lombardo you can always submit it online
just head to 8newsnow.com
you can find out if your question is
answered every wednesday 6 4